tonight is the second time that I have
seen Sandoval diminish the conception of
my
beautiful
magical daughter
I'm disgusted
Lala Kent slamming Tom Sandoval for
making a comment about her daughter
ocean that's where I draw the line you
can come for me all day long you leave
her out of this Lala's anger comes from
a moment on part two of the Vanderpump
Rules reunion during a heated argument
with Tom I never have an eagle
I ain't a narcissist yeah
it has nothing to do with it that does
so no it doesn't you
hold your IUD the day you found
out stashing is pregnant yeah Tom's
talking about how Lala's daughter was
conceived and former castimate stassi
Schroeder Lala welcomed ocean in March
2021 two months after Stasi gave birth
to daughter Hartford however Lala didn't
hear Tom's remark at the reunion but
she's heard it now and is not standing
for it I'm so glad that I did not hear
that at the reunion because I'm telling
you what these Mama Bear Paws what a mob
out of him Sandoval you better watch
your tongue when you talk about me you
keep my daughter out of your mouth that
baby was brought into this world out of
love respect and my my relationship may
have gone but that little girl is the
best thing that ever happened to me how
dare you I just want to be someone that
she's proud of and you know this
environment can bring out some emotions
we'll call them so that's the biggest
thing
Lala has been no stranger to standing up
to Tom at the pump rules reunion
especially addressing Tom's affair with
Raquel Levis which ended his nine-year
relationship with Ariana Maddox
behind everyone's back
I know that I know I am taking
accountability you are not
you're not
doing anything wrong I talked to Sheena
on the phone and not once did she
mention that she punched Raquel not a
once and I watched her tongue because
they're cute I heard it
being hurt the woman always takes the
brunt of the man's actions and you'll
see this season that I'm pretty
passionate about that not happening
anymore and Lala will be showing that
passion again when Raquel joins the cast
on part three of the reunion June 7.
James and Lola
because they
they thought you shut the up Lala
there was more how different was it
there was just so much on the table that
needed to be and everyone had things to
say so yeah I would say I mean that
being said
I've now done you know hundreds of
reunions so yeah I would say this is
gonna be this is going to be top ten
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign